es ist zwar schon halb zwei nachts und
ich sehe glaube ich ein bisschen wieder
aus wenn ich das da so richtig erkennen
kann
aber ich bin halt irgendwie gar nicht
mal so ich wollte nur gesagt haben damit
sie nicht auf die idee kommt du bist
oder du siehst schreibt dass ich in die
kommentare schreibt lieber in die
kommentare
das kennt wenn ihr halt müde aussieht
aber nicht müde seine leute was geht ab
herzlich willkommen beim neuen video und
zwar habe ich mir für heute gedacht das
ist ja zurzeit auch mega so trend auf
youtube meine kinder fotos
beziehungsweise fotos wo ich halt zehn
jahre 15 jahre jünger treffer ich habe
mir wirklich lange gedanken dazu gemacht
mache jetzt gegen video dazu weil es mal
ich freue mich immer so was gehört jetzt
weniger auf youtube und was nicht so ich
bin zu dem entschluss gekommen
ihr seid alle mal scheiße aus und ja ich
habe mir gedacht komm 34 fotos nimmst
einfach mal wenn's so lustig bisher was
dazu erzählen und ich nennt sich meine
beine kinderfotos ich finde das jetzt
nicht weniger sondern mehr vielleicht
meine kassen kinderbonus genau so nenne
ich das video und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß für unsere gefällt dass auf
jeden fall nach oben da und bereit viel
spaß so dann würde ich mal sagen wir
fangen an mit dem ersten foto und zwar
ist dass dieses hier
ich würde mal schätzen das ist so ja da
war ich so zwei oder drei und es sieht
echt lustig aus ich meinen die klamotten
sehen irgendwie ein bisschen groß aus
ich sehe aus als werde ich 60 cm groß
und der ball ist halt größer als mein
kopf also ich finde es lustig ich hab
das schon länger nicht mehr gesehen ich
wusste gar nicht dass es so was von mir
gibt mehr und es ist geil das nächste
foto habe ich in so einem alten album
von mir gefunden
das ist dieses hier uns war ich würde
mich da mal so auf 7 schätzen
vielleicht auf 8 und ich glaube ich
meine ich wusste es noch zu wissen
ich hatte da geburtstag und ich war mega
der tiger für ein und ab halte mir so
einen krassen tiger gewünscht und ich
war da glaube ich auch noch klein
ich würde mich so auf 120 schützen weil
der tiger ist höchstens 50 cm lange
riese ja ich finde
sieht lustig aus nahm aber man sieht
mich gar nicht weil der tiger fast
größer so leute jetzt kommt mein
lieblingsbild an die dies vielleicht zu
kassieren
schaltet vielleicht kurswechsel ist es
echt furchteinflößend ich finds mega
cool und zwar war ich halt in der
grundschule karneval war ich vier jahre
immer vampire und zwar ist er dieses
bild entstand
da war ich im wald habe ich mich in
meinen bambi outfit geschmissen und mein
kumpel rechne
wir sind dann halt immer so über den
schulhof gelaufen und gerade weil war
dies beim 4 kostüm an hatten dachten wir
sind schneller also wir haben wenn es
wirklich so gefühl dass wir schneller
unterwegs als hätte er das kostüm nicht
an da kann ich mich noch genau daran
erinnern als wäre es gestern gewesen
und ich habe da meine frisur habe ich
nicht mit wachs gemacht so wie jetzt
sondern mit so schwierigen gehe kennt
ihr das dieses alte gela was man so nah
und dann war das war so eklig und dann
waren die haare so richtig klitschnass
davon weil wachs kannte ich da noch gar
nicht gab es auch schon frage ich keine
ahnung ja passt auf irgendeinem bild was
ich auch auf jeden fall noch mit rein
nehmen wollte ich war jetzt zwar noch
nicht mehr ganz so jung aber ich war
auch nicht wirklich alt ich glaube ich
war da so 13 hatte aber schon ein
youtube kanal war und da habe ich mir
auch meine erste kamera geholt und ich
sage dir aus fünf jahre nicht mehr
versorgen wir sind ist es dieses bild
hier was ihr vielleicht schon ein
gebilden sich die materie 1 1 gewonnen
habt ohne scheiß wenn ich mir das jetzt
so angucke ich frage mich ernsthaft wie
konntest du bitte drei jahre lang mit
diesen langenhan die überhaupt nicht
mehr nach hahn außen sondern nach
irgendeiner weise die durcheinander
gekämmt ist wie conny so rund läuft ohne
scheiß und hat keine ahnung wann ich
bereue es überhaupt nicht dass ich mich
dann irgendwann dazu entschlossen habe
meine haare einfach jetzt mal
abzuschneiden und ich bin auch froh dass
ich jetzt meine haare sind und nicht so
scheiße wie auf diesem bild auch in
berlin freue ich sie immer noch genauso
aus
das waren jetzt mal vier fotos 3 davon
halte ich noch ziemlich jungen ob aussah
und ich habe natürlich noch ganz viele
andere lustige fotos jetzt gefunden
aber ich denke mal ihr könnt mich dabei
stehen wir nicht sagen ich zeige jetzt
diese drei fotos mehr nicht ist halt
jetzt meine meinung dazu
ja ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem
gefallen falls es der fall ist auf jeden
fall lohnen da oder schreibt in die
kommentare
und hier ist normal pattinson gewendet
und dann würde ich sagen hier auf der
linken seite geht's weiter mit einem
netz - das war mit meinem kumpel in
dinge die mädchen an jungs nicht
verstehen haben wir also ein paar verein
wartet hier auf der anderen seite haben
wir einfach mal mit meinem bruder das
erste video was ich mit meinem oder
gedrehter bereit
checkt auf jeden fall ab würde mich
freuen und wir sehen uns dann nächsten
samstag wieder drei leute